dann sind die kinder lieber tot als dass
die behörde am schluss recht behält und
die kinder wieder zurückgehen frank
urbaniok ist der einflussreichste und
wohl auch bekannteste gerichtspsychiater
der schweiz
wenn die medien fragen haben liefert er
antworten
wir sprechen mit ihm über die
eindrücklichsten fälle mit denen er als
gutachter zu tun hatte am neujahrstag
2015 tötete die damals 27 jährige mutter
ihre beiden kinder zwei und fünf jahre
alt vorausgegangen war dass die kinder
von der kinder und erwachsene schutz
behörde zuvor in einem heim platziert
wurden und die täterin selbst beginnen
dann acht monate später in
untersuchungshaft gesetzt
die kest erlaubt dass die kinder über
die feiertage bei der mutter in flach
sein dürfen
anschließend sollen sie vorüber gehen
zurück ins heim
die frau will das mit einer beschwerde
verhindern
als sie erfährt dass diese beschwerde
abgewiesen wurde tötet sie ihre kinder
also letztlich war das motiv dass es
einen machtkampf gab zwischen der
behörde die die kinder ins heim gebracht
hatten und der mutter die das auf gar
keinen fall akzeptieren wollte
akzeptieren konnte man könnte etwas
verkürzt sagen die aufgrund dieses
machtkampfes am schluss sogar bereit war
dann bis zur letzten konsequenz zu gehen
und zu sagen dann sind die kinder lieber
tot als dass die behörde am schluss
recht behält und die kinder wieder
zurückgehen
der tisch wird unter anderem vorgeworfen
sie hätte realisieren müssen was
passieren könnte wenn sie die frau
dermaßen in die enge treiben
wenn man alles gewusst hätte zum
damaligen zeitpunkt dann hätte man es
verhindern können aber man muss
fairerweise sagen diese problematik war
für die behörde unmöglich zu erkennen
für die behörde war die situation so die
namen auffälligkeiten war die namen war
das der bestimmte sagten die gesagt
wurden nicht stimmten für die stellten
sich fragen
es war aber wie eine verschlossene tür
in der die behörde nicht wusste was ist
hinter der tür und das dass hinter der
tür lauerte das wussten sie nicht dass
konnten sie nicht wissen und das ist ja
auch etwas was in dieser form extrem
selten ist von daher würde ich insgesamt
sagen theoretisch hätte man das wissen
können oder hätte das risiko zumindest
ahnen können praktisch hatte die behörde
keine möglichkeit weil die behörde die
informationen dafür gar nicht die mutter
der getöteten kinder hat sich bereits
das leben genommen als new york das
gutachten über sie schreibt ich habe
selbst mit der täterin nicht geredet
aber es ist nicht so dass das ein reines
akten gutachten war denn wir machen
gutachten sehr oft so dass wir das im
team machen das dann unterschiedliche
phasen in dem gutachten prozess laufen
und dann zum beispiel von mitarbeitern
bestimmte sachen schon gemacht werden
und in dem fall war es so dass sehr
ausführliche gespräche und explorationen
bereits vorlagen
die wurden durch eine enge mitarbeiterin
von mir geführt und ich war absolut im
bilde was dort gesprochen wurde was dort
der sachstand war weil wir diese
explorationen diese gespräche immer
vorher gesprochen hatten nach besprochen
haben und sofort die weitere strategie
festgelegt haben und da muss man
insgesamt sagen ich selber dazu ist es
dann nicht mehr gekommen dass sich
abschließend mit der täterin selber
sprechen konnte und dann zum beispiel
auf einige widersprüche noch mal selber
hinweisen konnte aber es lag damals eine
außerordentlich gute
informationsgrundlage war und man yorks
gutachten soll erklären wieso die beiden
kinder am ersten januar 2015 im haus
ihrer mutter sterben müssen
das hat viel mit grundlegenden
persönlichkeitseigenschaften der täterin
zu tun
ein sehr wichtiger ist der sogenannte
instabile realitätsbezug das bedeutet
dass menschen eigentlich das was sie
fühlen die gefühlte realität über die
tatsächliche realität setzen das heißt
sie können beliebig realitäten und
glaubenssätze austauschen und leben in
gewisser weise in einer scheinwelt in
der sie auch beliebig viele
möglichkeiten haben dass eine zu glauben
zu denken oder für richtig zu halten
es gibt eine fülle von beispielen die in
die richtung gehen dass die täterin
dinge erzählt hat die einfach nicht
stimmten und die aber aus dem gefühl
heraus ganz überzeugend vertreten wurde
sie erzielte dann der behörde dass sie
mit dem privatjet angeflogen sei sie
zusammen mit ihrem damaligen partner das
war so ein mietnomadentum dass man
wohnungen dort bewohnte und dann aber
keine miete zahlt wieder aus so dass man
als käufer auftrag von
großen immobilien aber ohne das geld zu
haben also es war immer ein leben seit
langer zeit an der wie soll man sagen
grenzen der realität oder man könnte
auch sagen viel mehr schein als sein und
wie die täterin selber war es aber nie
ein problem
dinge die für sie emotional stimmig
waren die sich gut anfühlten als die
realität anzusehen als die realität zu
verkaufen
und man kann generell sagen bei menschen
mit einem instabilen realitätsbezug ist
die wirklichkeit beliebig austauschbar
es gibt man muss keine grenze
überspringen um etwas falsches
wahrheitswidrige es zu vertreten oder zu
glauben weil innerlich ist es immer so
wenn es stimmt wenn es vom gefühl stimmt
dann ist damit die geschichte legitim
und verträge thema lebt anfang 2016
informiert die zürcher justizdirektion
über die ergebnisse von zwei gutachten
zum fall flach eines davon von urban
york sind optimal und beispielhaft sie
andere hand jahr gehörigen schlag könne
nachvollziehen was jetzt wirklich
passiert wieso behörde die und die
schritt macht was der rechtsgrund text
ist und teilweise sich endete gegen ihre
daumen und verbesserungen passieren bei
den großeltern hätte ein eingerichtetes
zimmer auf die kinder gewartet aber die
cash bevorzugte eine lösung in einem
kinderheim für die großeltern
unverständlich es ist keiner da was
darauf zu sehen da die heiße sind
deutschland-spiel grob begangen als sie
keine das spiel und agierte karte dazu
eine heute dass die hkk hotel gehalten
für mich zählt oder was die rolle der
großeltern ist ein absolut weiterer
tragischer aspekt dieses ganzen fall ist
wie die großeltern war so die kannten
ihre tochter die kannten diese
problematik die beobachteten von außen
dass sich das rad immer schneller dreht
das ist eine welt war die auf schein
aufgebaut war die machten sich sorgen um
die kinder
die sahen sich mehr in der rolle fasst
von reserve eltern und um da eine
gewisse stabilität dort zu gewährleisten
jetzt platzte das system das platzte ja
dadurch dass es zu einer inhaftierung
kam wegen betrugs handlungen und jetzt
sagen die großeltern natürlich den
zeitpunkt gekommen wo sie fast sagten
gut wenigstens kommt das jetzt mal zum
stillstand wenigstens kann man jetzt das
in geordnete bahnen lenken und waren
parat die kinder zu übernehmen
aus ihrer sicht absolut ehrenwert und
verständlich und wahrscheinlich auch
wäre wäre das eine gute lösung gewesen
jetzt verstehe ich aber auch die behörde
die kinder und erwachsene schutz behörde
für die wirkt das komisch dass plötzlich
von einem moment auf den anderen in form
der großeltern reserve eltern zur
verfügung stehen und die stellen sich
die frage aber wenn die jetzt die kinder
so übernehmen kann man die mutter dann
überhaupt später noch mal wieder
installieren als mutter also wird waren
die etwas reserviert den großeltern
gegenüber und die großeltern konnten das
gar nicht verstehen weil die kanten die
situation gesehen aber das ist doch
jetzt genau der zeitpunkt wo wir genau
in die bresche springen müssen und so
schaukelte sich das gegenseitig mit
einem gewissen misstrauen hoch aus der
subjektiven sicht beider seiten durchaus
verständlich aber natürlich im ergebnis
absolut tragisch absolut tragisch weil
es kam dann deswegen gerade nicht dazu
dass man den großeltern sofort die
kinder zum ab und übergab mit den
entsprechenden folgen
der fall löste eine nationale debatte
über die gäste aus die bis heute
andauert